development on project M a popular
modding project for 2008 super smash
brothers brawl has ended the team behind
the initiative announced the news in a
post on its website today they've been
working on project m for more than six
years but I've decided to bring things
to a close rather than let it drag on
quote we realize that this will come as
a shock to many of our fans please
forgive us again it's been an
excruciating call to make but it's been
made a bit easier buyer satisfaction
with the previous and final release
version 3.6 we spent six years polishing
project m and rather than let it drag on
through another several years of
dwindling development and change fatigue
in the competitive circle we're going to
consider our work complete the team
behind project end is hard at work on
unspecified new projects which are being
quote built from the ground up
representatives said we can't spill the
beans just yet but know that we're
looking towards a fresh start with brand
new designs rather than splitting our
focus many of us want to dedicate
ourselves to this new venture fully in
this way we hope to maintain the level
of quality and professionalism you've
come to expect from us files for project
m which had been available for free are
no longer featured on the team's website
in fact the entire website has been
scrubbed clean except for the shutdown
announcement